yes this number is disappointing the
numbers came in much lower than expected
for the this month and they had to
revise downward those July numbers they
were even in negative territory so if we
think factory orders are the most
important thing to watch when getting a
gauge of the churn mcconomy things don't
look great of course there's a whole lot
of other data out there most of them are
a little bit lagging and we still have
not yet priced in the effect of the
Volkswagen scandal on the German economy
as a whole probably at this stage only
see in the very beginning of who might
you know file claims against Volkswagen
and I think it will be really difficult
to estimate how much more will come over
the next few years and the key question
that will be raised as will the company
actually run into financial problems
well maybe the German stayed have to
intervene obviously this is speculation
at this point but that's the main
question
you do have to be worried about Germany
whenever there's concern about global
growth I mean Germany's very very tied
into that so whenever the markets
concerned about that with a lag it
normally feeds through to Germany and I
think we're seeing the bit of these
effects right now at first Merkel was
very open for example to receiving the
migrants everybody was saying this is
great this could change Germany's legacy
almost in the world and it has turned
around really fast and now everybody's
talking about the Volkswagen scandal and
to what effect that could impact the
German you know export brand which is
significant for Germany's economy is
very much based on on its export
performance if there's really a
challenge to its image then that could
have a significant effect